comme ça ou quand vous avez envie de
rouler une pelle à une fille vous dites
quoi est ce que vous vous demandez vous
avant jean michel maire avant de rouler
une pelle ah oui c'est mieux à vous
demander ne manquent pas il subit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean-michel produits c'est vrai qu'on
vous fait vous vous y aller mais vous
proposez quoi comme question avance que
vous avez une phrase fétiche l'enjeu
je regarde un peu bas comme certains
gibelotte is un peu avec les yeux quand
je sens qu'elle a un peu en train de
commettre
je vous fait line bertrand pour voir
comme ça allez-vous passer à l'alcool à
90 ou plus mais où est-ce que vous avez
une technique gilles verdez maintenant
je fais comme bush par le plus jaser
tout de suite et après on me reproche le
mec qui sort salon du bois sur quoi il
va tomber il ya des mecs avec des mecs
je ne sors plus de chez finansbank dadou
là bas je demandais dit est-ce que
chérie tu serais des trucs un peu en
tôle or comme ça ça tombait à plat et en
10e et d'où tu demandes savais pas que
tu me demande où tu te barres paye
[Rires]
si c'est quand j'étais plus jeune je
suis d'éviter qu'on embrasse allons
directement à l'essentiel
quoique away d'accord
c'est que c'est compliqué pour le cobra
parce que ouais pour pénétrer discret
d'avancé sur moi j'ai pas confiance en
moi donc je propose un service tamir dit
est ce que tu voudrais que je te
détartrer au regard des bonnes méthodes
la méthode à l'éclair c'est quoi je
viens chez avec moctar bien moi qui
l'avais dit je vous voulez dire c'est
que j'avais un monoski à la maison je me
servais du monoski c'était nul à chiens
c'est à dire que je faisais comme ça
avec la fille je disais tu as vu mon tas
mais au moins tu as vu mon monoski on
vous faisait quand même pas ce à quoi
qu'est-ce que ça va pas marcher l'an
[Rires]
dernier - cham au kenya paris ou la
vache
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m'asseoir à table j'attendais